depuis leur création en allemagne il ya
presque cent ans
les gars me berg contiennent soit de la
gomme arabique ou de la gélatine
d'origine animale
mais signe des temps certains deviennent
aujourd'hui végétalienne
moi ce que j'ai fait dans mes deux yeux
parce que j'ai simplement pris les
purées de fruits naturels les bonbons
gélifiés végétalien ne contiennent pas
de gélatine ni aucun autre produit
dérivé d'un animal d'un poisson ou d'un
insecte
on prête à déposer une figure sombre et
la pectine de l'agar agar ou la fécule
de maïs
par contre j'ai une petite préférence je
voudrais pour la fécule de maïs qui est
beaucoup plus accessible et moins
dispendieuse les saveurs les formes et
les couleurs sont semblables aux
friandises traditionnels c'est dans la
texture qu'on remarque une différence
l'agar agar va être beaucoup plus de
casse en vous allez voir là dedans il se
comporte pas de la même façon que les
autres
la fécule de maïs vaudra en plus tendres
vrais fruits sans gluten sans ogm sans
gras trans végétaliens ou végétariens et
un bon bon ça reste un bonbon quand on
regarde la liste d'ingrédients
débourrement conventionnelles comme
librement végétalien le premier
ingrédient ac dc créé le suc sympa plus
en paix c'est pas qu'une utilité
les teneurs en sucre sont aussi très
élevé dans les poumons des italiens
l'ont pourrait vouloir acheter bon
végétalien seulement pour essayer
d'avoir un impact un peu moins important
sur la planète pu aussi en termes
d'ingrédients parfois ils vont tous des
colorants qui sont plus naturels
[Musique]
on va utiliser par exemple ça peut être
de la betterave du curcumin des choses
qui vont colorer aussi naturellement nos
bonbons et que c'est ça qui va faire en
effet que 1 va se démarquer un petit peu
des bonbons plus traditionnelles qu'on
peut trouver à l'épicerie l'entreprise
montréalaise squeeze propose une grande
variété de bonbons végétalien ça permet
d'offrir un peu plus de bonbons
différents à des communautés aussi comme
les communautés musulmanes qui sont
vraiment contents de pouvoir avoir des
bonbons qu'ils peuvent manger puisque en
a retiré la gélatine de porc animal
dedans malgré les apparences et les
différentes compagnies québécoises ou
canadiennes ne fabrique pas leurs
bonbons en gelée puisqu'il n'existe
aucune usine de ce type au canada les
bonbons viennent essentiellement
d'europe d'allemagne puisque c'est le
concret allegheny peu ils sont à la base
des bonbons des juges une toute
l'expertisé est vraiment la base en
europe
nous en tant que compagnie qui vais
croiser montréalaise mais on travaille
beaucoup en allemagne aussi pour des
bonbons légèrement plus santé on peut
toujours le faire à la maison
c'est assez simple ça fait très fort
aussi pour l'activité en soi donc si on
s'assied le des enfants comprend enfin
vos propres jeux chop c'est super
intéressant
une purée de fruits ou même de juin un
agent gélifiants et évidemment du sucre
ont produit environ jusqu'à trois fois
intérieure ensuite par contre j'avoue
sont prévues jusqu'à ce que point là les
jupes sont moins sucré en termes de ça
va on va vraiment pu percevoir la
différence
pour ce qui est des purées de fruits
gérer en plus la purge a ajouté encore
le dise et qu'on dira donc si règne plus
que tout les surgelés ou pourrait
prendre des fruits frais aussi et là on
va acheter une petite abord j'ai mis un
petit peu de jus de l'hémostase une
version pour avoir un petit côté de tic
ainsi que je veux aussi qu'on va acheter
la gare ailleurs dans notre opération on
ajoute l'agent gélifiant à la
préparation à faire chauffer et ensuite
c'est vraiment très bon esprit de la
terre dans un petit moule en silicone on
lire ça lorsqu'ils sont signifiées et
c'est tout c'est vraiment ultra ultra
sélect a décidé de combiner les deux
actuellement c'est ça la différence
c'est qu'on peut en même temps voir ça
fonctionne avec n'importe quel prix
[Musique]
c'est vrai que c'est une belle activité
avec les enfants vont comprendre ce que
sait faire des bonbons à la maison avec
des ingrédients de qualité
ici on ne se libère base de jus de
cerise avec le sirop d'érable ont des
petits l'hippopotame c'est bien mignon
ça c'est ça c'est la même qu'on ait fait
de tentes aux attentes ont mis un
tourment un peu plus grand et à fraises
et celui que je verse ici ça va être
celui avec du jus d'orange du kampuchea
pas content pour garder des bénéfices
comme vous tchèque vous l'ajoutez plus
tard on peut pas de chauffer les jours
sont comme butcher qui l'eût cru
on est dans un autre univers embauché
faut pas penser qu'on va retrouver le
goût de deux titres sont appelés du
conventionnel à moins d'utiliser de la
pectine où l'on va se rapprocher un
public mais si on regarde si j'en avais
fait aussi avec la fécule de maïs mais
j'ai mis un petit peu moins on qui est
vraiment plus
il rebondit beaucoup plus il peut se
gélifie long mais ayez pauvreté en
termes perdre
moi je trouve que la fécule de maïs nous
donne quelque chose qui est un peu moins
dépaysant embauche donc agar agar fécule
de maïs pectine et trois absents de ce
panier qu'on peut avoir à la maison
[Musique]